er liebte die mensch und die malerei
johannes itten künstler und legendärer
pädagoge am bauhaus
wer hätte das erwartet sowie seine
geschichte beginnt
1888 im berner oberland als bauern tot
geboren beginnt er zwar schon als knabe
zu malen
doch seine verwandten verbieten es ihm
es heißt das sei unnütz
er wird lehrer zunächst und studiert
erst danach an der kunstakademie in genf
doch er ist enttäuscht vom unterricht
von sturm kopieren der vorbilder von den
bevormundungen der professoren
dennoch wird den künstler in stuttgart
und wien beginnt er seine eigene kunst
pädagogik zu entwickeln und lernt walter
gropius kennen
der ist gründer der bauhaus schule und
beruf täter 1919 als eine der ersten
lehrer nach weimar die schule bricht
konsequent mit den klassischen akademien
und etabliert eine neue kunst ausbildung
bieten wird zum chef lehrer und baut
alle werkstätten auf in denen die
studierenden mit verschiedensten
materialien experimentieren auch mit
seiner im bauhaus entwickelten
farbenlehre betritt er pädagogisches
neuland
doch bevor sich die studierenden für
eine fachrichtung entscheiden
besuchen sie eine basisausbildung den
vorkurs eingeführt von johannes itten
der fokus ist noch heute ein vielen
kunstschulen eine wichtige vorbereitung
auf das design und kunst studium auch an
der zürcher hochschule der künste
hier gilt das sogenannte propädeutikum
als erfolgversprechende brücke zwischen
schule und studium eine sehr
individuelle bestimmte und selbständiger
arbeit wie es finde sie solch einer lage
wo fühle ich mich am wohlsten fühle ich
mich im flachen am besten zum beispiel
bin ich bin ich mit analogen mittel öle
als mit digitalen mitteln du nicht gar
nich mit materialien beschäftigen und
mit qualitäten womit plastische
sachverhalt mit römischer vorausgeht
die ganz grundlegende sachen soll
urlauber und nicht nur abstrakt
individuelles erleben stadtakademie
siert im unterricht genau das ist damals
die idee hinter eatons vorkurs jener
neuen arzt am bauhaus gestaltung zu
leeren
der tag beginnt mit körper- und
atemübungen
sie sollen die studierenden für den
unterricht fitmacher geist und körper so
meinten seien untrennbar miteinander
verbunden
zum unterricht gehört auch dass akt
malen neu ist nicht mehr das modell
abzeichnen sondern seine bewegung
du musst nur empfindungen wiedergeben
bewegungen den rhythmus erfassen nicht
überlegen ganz schnell gehen sagt den
studierenden nie wie etwas am schluss
aussehen soll
es geht ihm um das wecken des kreativen
geistes so schickt er die studierenden
hinaus auf die straße um gegenstände zu
sammeln aus denen sie später objekte
bauen soll
die wichtigste aufgabe im vorkurs sieht
darin den studierenden zu helfen sich
selbst zu finden experimentierens den
eigenen gestalterischen weg zu finden
das ist auch eines der ziele des
publikums an der zhdk mit dieser
offenheit tun sie studierende manchmal
aber auch schwer möglich sondern
menschen bildung und individuelle
förderung der studierenden sind für ihn
zentral aber aus walter gropius hingegen
will die studierenden fit machen für die
industrie und gropius setzt sich durch
das bauhaus wird zur wiege des
industriellen die salz und johannes
itten verlässt nach erst
dreieinhalbjähriger lehrtätigkeit die
schule
er gründet 1926 eine eigene kunst schule
in berlin wo er seine pädagogik
weiterentwickelt die innovative schule
passt allerdings nicht in die kunst
vorstellung der nationalsozialisten
hätten erleidet 1934 dasselbe schicksal
wie seine früheren kollegen seine schule
wird wie das bauhaus geschlossen
der erneuerer der kunstpädagogik kommt
zurück nach zürich und unterrichtet
erfolgreich weiter unter anderem an der
kunstgewerbeschule
so wie er als bauhaus pionier dachte so
denkt er immer noch
auch hier ist die kreativität der
studierenden das erklärte ziel eine
seiner studentinnen aus den 50er jahren
erinnert sich plan war es eine
lebensphase und wenn dir ein mann dachte
ich bin ja ich mache das in blautönen
das gefällt ihm sicher dann wurde er
ganz unglaublich das durfte man nicht
weil er war jemand der uns gelehrt hat
eigenständig zu sein
johannes itten ein lehrmeister der das
bauhaus prägte ein großer pädagoge im
seminar schon habe ich mit leichtigkeit
unterricht gegeben so dass das
pädagogische eigentlich ganz natürlicher
weise
da war die pädagogischen fähigkeiten
[Musik]